toutes ces batailles pendant toutes ces
années mais aucune ne ressemble à celle
ci sommes-nous destiné à nous entretuer
ou pourrons nous changer qui nous sommes
et unir nos forces
l'avenir est il déjà écrit
mi temps
nous sommes aujourd'hui menacés
d'extinction tu devra retourner dans le
passé
pour finir cette guerre avant même
qu'elle commence
déploie tes pouvoirs rassemble tous les
x men
il faudra qu'on soit 2 côte à côte
à une époque où tout nous sépare
ce que j'avais de plus précieux tu me
l'a pris
peut-être aurait-il fallu le défendre
nous avons un nouvel ennemi les mutants
il vous faudra de nouvelles armes
je sais ce que j'ai à faire c'est eux ou
nous
toutes ces années perdues à nous entre
déchirer chars
trop de gens mourir
tes poches
on nous accorde une seconde chance
guy tu nous emmènes non
je ne veux pas de ton avenir
c'était à nous de les protéger
tu as peur je me le rappelle